[Music]
when we started talking about this movie
in terms of a sense of adventure an
action sequence on a train was something
we'd always wanted to do
we wanted to build upon the previous
films and apply all of that knowledge to
something practical and real and bring
this train sequence to another level
there was not a surplus of trains
available to be wrecked we had to build
the train if we wanted to destroy it
to shoot it practically it was extremely
challenging
not just to execute but also to design
all the different train cars that could
actually function on a working railroad
track
no one else in the world is doing this
level of practical filmmaking and it may
never be done again
the train sequence takes us in an
adventure that's absolutely huge we have
this big fly on the roof going 60 miles
an hour through a real Valley
I've done fight scenes but to do them on
a moving train it was trial by fire
that's how Tom likes to do things
foreign
Carriage Tom's a great person to have
beside you not only is he Fearless he is
always looking to see how it's going to
land for the audience
[Music]
crash in the train involved multiplying
factors of difficulty you'd be chasing
the train as it goes on every single
camera they had exactly one shot at
getting it right not just a matter of
going off because if we do it all we
don't capture it right what's the point
everything you are seeing in this
spectacular train sequence is done to
invest the audience in these characters
Mission Impossible is the most
extraordinary Adventure franchise you've
ever seen you could only do it with a
team like this and with an actor like
Tom
foreign
[Music]